hi guys welcome to the just pearly songs
youtube channel today
i'm going to be reacting to a song that
i was told
do not react to i asked my boyfriend who
listens to rap music
and i said should i react to this and he
told me no
but since you guys got me to 10 000
subscribers
in my first month i'm gonna do it for
you guys drum roll please
a low budget i know drilla 51
dead ops now i can only imagine what
this is about
i'm kind of nervous before i start do
not forget
subscribe subscribe subscribe i've been
bouncing around from place to place
i would love to get my own place and the
more subscribers i get
the closer i get to that dream of moving
out
while you're at it comment below do you
think that my reaction was accurate or
did i get something wrong and
like the video while you're at it i'm
nervous honestly
okay so just to start um i want to
explain a couple things that i learned
so far through my reactions so they're
in a kitchen that's not that nice
this is likely a trap house there's a
lot of people in there
partying they have a lot of friends
which could be a gang
however this is a little different
because typically when it's this setting
in the videos i've watched it's been all
dudes
but now we got a couple ladies our
ladies in gangs
a question i have i'm going to continue
real quick i'm going to call drill wick
don't play bit
man down gang [ __ ] party all day [ __ ]
poppin pills crazy
pyramid booty
okay so he's talking about doing some
drugs i think he
mentioned ecstasy i think that's one of
them
but yeah it's it's important to him to
do drugs
huh they had a fake beginning i don't
something's coming soon but i don't know
what exactly is coming soon
okay wait so it's 51 dead ops because
ops
is opposition and opposition either it's
gang members
or the cops so i think there might be
51 dead cops
that's crazy
it looks like that he wants a new
girlfriend
but he likes the sexual favors that he
gets from her
so he doesn't want to let her go ladies
if you're in this situation i recommend
finding a new man
this is too fast i gotta replay this but
she suck me up some snoring
till then i'm keeping blocks around
trying to catch me up i can do it by
myself the next cop take in that room
they gonna hit from the top
but you know i'm on the block all day
come get sir i'm trying to catch every
play i really slide to the 6th
day really think about it that day [ __ ]
it finna get respectful i hit you my
rhyming time
with the left i think he's saying
that he like runs his little block
and like he's not afraid
to kill people whoever the op is it's
either the opposition or the cops i
don't know which
i wish they wish came and got you back
at that back too
the boot got held in the drive with he
fixed on the car his head was on the top
right hand got hit on the fighters one
noise golden girl to die
wish he wanted
is he saying that he shot someone on the
driveway
oh dear this is what i was told not to
react to this song
oh my god we call that [ __ ] got
it cuz itself ain't make to the doctor
[Music]
oh i don't like this song at all
he's i think he's saying that he's like
he's describing a murder
that's not good that is not good at all
[Music]
okay so they're describing peeing on
this guy's grave i think
and everyone's crying and he just
doesn't care
what what and now he made a song about
it that
is saint got hit on the seventh early in
the morning to heaven smoking on carly
died from cancer obi was sick lord he
sent them a present
and lulu got hit on the hit [ __ ] got
hit in that [ __ ]
rob's on
okay it looks like there's other people
dying maybe the guy died from
cancer someone died from cancer and
someone's in heaven which is good
he led a good life that's a good thing
yeah wrote down the stone triggered it
too
look got killed by his brother's body
[ __ ] he look real slow big mo
picking side so we gave my stoke and we
dropping l's follower mo
brady's who how you want ready to go
shout out to the g's [ __ ] chris mo
shout out to the g [ __ ] chris multi roy
double
too look got killed by his bro was body
[ __ ] he looked real slow big mo
picking side so we gave him a stoke and
we dropping hills following mo
frederickson how you want ready to go
shout out to the g's [ __ ] chris mo
shout out to the g [ __ ] chris multi
royale down with this 2x don't get well
we forgot about that
okay so there's a lot going on here i
don't understand half of it but
i so i heard one important thing
he likes apple jacks and i personally
think that is a great cereal choice like
i
10 out of 10 would recommend i don't
think i recommend
anything else from this song but apple
jacks i can't argue with that
bro i don't know him either way so i'm
glad he finished
yeah so he said f tayski i don't know
him either
i don't know who tayski is
is that a person like maybe it's like a
a snitch or something
i got hit on the bricks hk really trying
to shoot
[ __ ] [ __ ] hold your homie [ __ ] say
night for the flat head dude
oh my gosh i just understood the whole
song
he was describing 51
dead people that died that were ops and
how they died
and he's saying that's 51 dead ops
and i hope i don't go to jail
okay one that's a bold move i would not
want to be his lawyer
i'm gonna start there second off
this is a really messed up song i can't
even pretend to like this
guys i can't [ __ ]
[ __ ] your homie
so he's saying f you're homie she's your
friend that
died and he's saying most of them have
been shot in the head
that is
i like i don't even know what to say
this is the most
messed up song i've ever listened to
[ __ ] your homie
[ __ ] your homie [ __ ] your homie most of
them
so if he said so he named 51 oppositions
that were dead i think
and now he's saying if you want me come
get me that is a bold
move that's a bold move because
like if i was their family members like
i mean i would probably go to the police
right that's what i would do but like
otherwise like
if there was someone like that would
come after him like that's kind of a
dangerous situation to be put in
i don't know if i should post this this
is why
one year told me not to who
hated that song um except for the apple
jacks
i would also recommend apple jacks but
other than that that was
only positive the only positive
i can't that was a terrible song i could
see why i was told not to react to this
so
if you still like my channel after this
video
which if you don't i don't even blame
you that was terrible
you know subscribe so i can't even like
say subscribe in a normal way because
i'm like triggered
subscribe comment like
i hate it here i do not
yeah thanks again for ten thousand
follow or
ten thank you again for ten thousand
subscribers
but i like having trouble looking at you
guys i
i i don't
i'm gonna just end the video now